let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 see what's on people's minds starting
with our caller from the 9 to 9 area
code caller from 9 to 9 who's this hi
from New York City hey ID nun what's
going on I'm just a quick question Dom
but a huge fan of the show by the way
what was what are your thoughts on the
Democrats standing ascending up giving
Donald Trump a standing ovation and
clapping and you know yelling USA USA
over and over again I know it was sort
of sarcastic I mean it was so so the
moment at which they did that was when
Donald Trump mentioned that a whole
bunch of women were elected to Congress
and of course they're almost all
Democrats and they're all against Trump
and the idea was they're applauding the
fact that anti Trump sentiment pushed
all of these new female candidates at
least partially into office because of
the political climate so it was sort of
tongue-in-cheek was my interpretation of
it mm-hmm
understood um and what are your thoughts
on just Nancy Pelosi you know
continuously standing up and clapping I
know she was kind of she was in a
position where she kind of had to do
that but you know that time to seem a
mocking but other times when Donald
Trump says socialism cannot be part of
the United States and she got up and she
clapped cheerfully and it didn't seem
like you know she was being sarcastic at
that point what are your thoughts on
that
yeah I mean I hate the entire charade
that is when you do and don't clap at
the State of the Union and the it it
ends up with exactly the situation
you're describing where okay Nancy
Pelosi is not a socialist Trump says
socialist socialism has no place here
and we've defeated socialism etc etc if
you don't sew socialism is not actually
a threat like there's no chance that the
u.s. is about to become socialist
there's no great clamoring for actual
socialism so it's a totally empty threat
and sort of a red meat comment to
Trump's base but if she doesn't clap
then all of a sudden it sounds like she
supports socialism it's so stupid the
entire paradigm around when you do and
don't clap and the big thing is you're
supposed to respond where if the Pres
something that you agree with you clap
even if you night disagree with 95% of
what he says and that's what we get this
this game that's played you know in my
opinion you know Bernie's and AOC
Stoicism or where they were just sitting
down adamantly and you know giving this
a stare of just like you know
disappointment you know really showed
you know their position and how they
realize at that moment oh like the whole
everyone else they're just bunch of
goons there are idiots and they don't
realize that socialism you know it's
already happening and you know they're
just clapping and he's just making fun
of it you know I was always so there was
some happening though in in in in my
views when it comes to like you know how
well the democratic socialist movement
of the when it comes to the TSA the
grassroot movements City we have a lot
of involvement a lot of people are just
you know joining groups like DSA other
grassroots organization that you know
values you know socialist type you know
movement and you know and that's
something while is discussing with my
you know just colleagues and friends you
know that's with you know we're we're
saying hey like we see that this is you
know continuously growing slowly and
slowly in the fact that Donald Trump is
threatened by this you know idea shows
that like you know we're moving
somewhere at least you know there's I
just don't think I'll agree I mean I
don't know of any serious socialist
policy or idea that is actually getting
traction you know Medicare for all is
something that but all you know
capitalist Western countries have Trump
being afraid of socialism fear of
socialism has been around for a really
really long time
a regardless of whether that quote
threat actually exists so that part I
disagree with but I do agree with you
that that the sort of pomp and
circumstance around the clapping is very
very silly okay I've got a bunch of
other people to get to so I'm gonna let
you go